many of us have been following the fact  that  things aren't looking so good for bees  for many years but there is now the fear  that the wing virus could even further  destroy honeybee populations and you  know one of the things i always think  about when i think about bees  is that with so many other  animals  uh think cows think chickens  if half of them died during the winter  and you didn't know why we would call it  a crisis if uh those who raise cattle  for example  came in in april and half of them were  just dead and they didn't know why  we'd call it a crisis it would be all  over the news everywhere and yet now  regularly half of honeybee  hives will just die during the winter  those who raise the bees don't know why  and it barely even makes the news